es sind massive freiheits
einschränkungen bei diesen freiheits
einschränkungen muss gefragt werden ob
sie wirklich wirksam die pandemie
bekämpfen ob sie tatsächlich die wirkung
die man sich von ihnen verspricht haben
werden und es stellt sich die frage
warum so weitgehende freiheit
einschränkungen schon wieder ohne eine
breite parlamentarische diskussion
beschlossen werden sollen
und warum auch nicht über alternativen
gesprochen wird
gerade jetzt in diesen minuten stellen
ärzte und ihre logen ein alternatives
konzept vor das nicht auf verbote
sondern auch verhaltensempfehlungen
setzt das stärker gefährdete
personengruppen etwa ältere menschen in
pflegeeinrichtungen schützt das aber
nicht das ganze land herunterfahren will
also zumindest debattieren über solche
alternativen möglichkeiten die pandemie
zu bekämpfen müsste in unserer
gesellschaft eigentlich die regel sein
das passiert hier leider nicht
wenn sie jetzt diesen vorstoß in die
beschlussvorlage kritisieren ihr
partei-vize wolfgang kubicki spricht von
alarmismus dann sagen sie doch mal bitte
noch mal ganz konkret was würden sie
anders machen als die bundeskanzlerin
und vor allem als die
ministerpräsidenten wir müssen uns
konzentrieren auf die wirklich wirksame
maßnahmen um die pandemie zu bekämpfen
gerade in den letzten wochen sind diese
beherbergungs verbote von gerichten
aufgehoben worden
ich erinnere mal daran dass die gerichte
nicht überzeugt waren davon dass es
wirklich eine bremsende wirkung für die
pandemie hätte wenn man auf
geschäftsreisen und auf familienurlaub
verzichtet das gericht aufgehoben haben
das kommt jetzt
kurze zeit später wieder das halte ich
für keine kluge politische entscheidung
wenn es so käme denn wir müssen uns auf
die maßnahmen konzentrieren die wirklich
die infektion herunterbringen und das
sind massenveranstaltungen die nicht
stattfinden können das ist
die vernachlässigung der regeln im
alltag stichwort abstand hygiene alltags
maske lüften und eine hoffentlich noch
weiter verbesserte corona app aber
pauschale schließungen des landes die
sind nicht an jeder stelle nötig und
dort wo das land geschlossen wird obwohl
es nicht nötig ist weil die fallzahlen
beispielsweise in einer gemeinde gering
sind da wirft das neue rechtsfragen auf
wie wir das beim beherbergungs verbot
gesehen haben der fehler wird also
sehenden auges ein zweites mal gemacht
wenn wir nicht aufpassen
wir müssen uns vor zwei dingen hüten das
erste ist die verharmlosung und
relativierung von corona es ist eine
gefährliche erkrankung insbesondere für
ältere und für gesundheitlich
vorgeschädigte menschen ist das eine
ganz ernsthafte gefahr
die darf nicht verharmlost werden und
auf der anderen seite aber müssen wir
uns hüten vor aktionismus und vor
panikmache herr lauterbach spricht heute
davon
dieser dieser neue stillstand diese
wellenbrecher strategie das sei so
wörtlich die letzte patrone
das sind doch formulierungen mit denen
panik gemacht werden soll und was
passiert wenn sich eben kein dauerhafter
erfolg durch diese maßnahmen einstellt
wenn die zahlen wieder hoch gehen auch
angst davor dass man weihnachten nicht
mit der familie verbringen kann
empfiehlt sich nicht als eine kluge
kommunikation mit den menschen
wir müssen ganz nüchtern die gefahren
sehen müssen ganz nüchtern die richtigen
entscheidungen treffen die möglichst
viel freiheit verbinden mit dem
gesundheitsschutz
die unverletzlichkeit der wohnung ist
ein verfassungsgebot diese
unverletzbarkeit der privaten räume der
intimsphäre die es ja sogar garantiert
im falle der terrorabwehr
herr lauterbach schlägt also maßnahmen
vor die schärfer sind als die bei der
terrorismusabwehr und das kann ich nicht
mehr als verhältnismäßig betrachten und
das ist mit sicherheit auch nicht
verfassungsgemäß was er da vor schlägt
man kann nur an alle appellieren weiter
mit augenmaß auch in einer pandemie zu
argumentieren
der konkrete vorschlag ist dass die
verluste des jahres 2020 verrechnet
werden können
mit den gewinnen der jahre 2018 und 2009
10 bei der steuer das hilft vom solo
selbstständigen über die freischaffende
künstlerin bis zur handwerkerinnen und
den industrieunternehmen der gesamten
deutschen wirtschaft weiter zu
investieren und arbeitsplätze zu
erhalten es ist mir ein rätsel warum
dieses ganz einfache instrument im
steuerrecht von der regierung bislang
nicht genutzt worden ist das braucht
keine bürokratie und dem staat entgeht
noch nicht einmal viel geld denn die
verluste werden zurückgetragen im
anderen fall würden sie nach vorne in
die zukunft verlegt nach dem geltenden
recht das heißt es noch nicht einmal ein
großer ausfall von steuermitteln sondern
nur aktuell eine wichtige
liquiditätshilfe für die betriebe
ich fordere dass diese maßnahme ganz
schnell beschlossen wird um gesunde
betriebe die eine fortsetzung aussicht
haben um die auch tatsächlich zu
erhalten
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dir das nächste video an
und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren